it's just the fact that um Game Pass had
to be uh an established platform and
from that business model you can disarm
a ton of uh individuals you can disarm
the people that's leaking the game
information out you can disarm um a lot
of the haters you can disarm Metacritic
because
as much as you guys
say that Metacritic doesn't uh formulate
how you play games it's a large
contendant that run with those numbers
and play games based on numbers because
they think that a game that's in the 90s
more people plays it so they're in with
the In Crowd opposed to a game that you
know got a 60 because I'm pretty sure
there's somebody out there that loves
for spoken it's like I don't know what
the hell they talking about this is
worth every last bit of my seventy
dollars and that's their leads to the
whole I don't like
um people